beauté
oh
pour tous
7 heures du matin le bidonville de ram
jean hagard et déjà réveillé depuis
longtemps
ses 6000 habitants vont comme chaque
matin essayer de gagner leur vie à
bombay la mégalopole toute proche
cecci 25 ans commencent toujours sa
journée par une prière à ganesh
c'est mon dieu
l'étude de la réussite comme son grand
père et son père il fait partie de la
corporation des dab awala les livreurs
de repas
mon père m'a tout appris il m'emmenait
avec lui après avoir passé mon bac es en
trois quatre jours il m'enseignait
toutes les ficelles du métier
être livreur de repas à bombay n'est pas
à la portée de n'importe qui il faut
d'abord un fidèle compagnon un vélo
performant
il s'appelle super face
face parce que je le conduis super vite
[Musique]
le temps est compté aujourd'hui satchi
va devoir collecter 35 repas au domicile
de ses clients éparpillés dans le nord
de bombay
il aura quatre heures pour les livrer
sur leur lieu de travail c'est le débat
voilà
sept shiva de porte en porte d'étagé en
étage pour récupérer les déjeuners
encore chaud
d'abord l'air
ah oui attendait j'arrive
son temps est compté mais pas toujours
celui de ses riches clients il peut bien
attendre cinq minutes
mon mari doit partir vers 7h le matin
c'est impossible pour moi de cuisiner
pour lui avant qu'il parte mais grâce et
d'abats voilà son déjeuner arrive à 13
heures au bureau
pour tous les clients le tarif est le
même 7 euros par mois pour 5 livraison
par semaine
à 10h satchi a déjà collecté 20 boîtes
en fer
45 kg à transporter
je ne suis pas fatigué le matin mais
parfois la fin de la journée à cause de
la pollution et de la chaleur j'ai mal
aux mains et aux jambes
la seule façon de prendre des vacances
pour moi et bien c'est tombé malade
cette chine vient de terminer à temps la
collecte en route pour le centre de
bombay avec son chargement
là
avec toutes les boîtes ça pèse à peu
près 70 kg
pour rejoindre le quartier d'affaires de
bombay un seul moyen de transport
possible le train en voiture il faudrait
quatre heures pour traverser la ville
c'est le réseau ferroviaire de bombay
très développé et unique en inde qui
permet aux dab awala d'exister
la confrérie est né en 1881 avec
l'arrivée du train dans cette ville
dans le wagon satchi retrouve les autres
dawala du quartier chacun avec ses boned
ils peignent sur les boîtes un code une
lettre pour la gare d'arrivée une
couleur pour le quartier un chiffre pour
le livreur est un numéro pour les tables
pas question de mélanger les repas ce
matin dans le train le président de la
corporation est venu vérifier que chacun
avait respecté les consignes
à bombay dans un même immeuble il peut y
avoir 20 familles qui viennent de
religion ou de régions différentes des
gujarat idée pendjabi des végétariens
des musulmans c'est impossible de
trouver une telle variété de nourriture
dans les cantines ou dans les
restaurants
[Musique]
je me sens mieux dans le train quand on
est ensemble tous dans le même wagon
j'oublie tous mes soucis nous sommes en
fait les rois du train
hop
à victoria station de la gare centrale
de bombay deux cent mille euros pas
avons changé de mains
les 5000 da ba voila de la ville se
croiser
quentin
[Musique]
chacun une zone de livraison
dans un coin de la gare satchi les
autres da ba voila se répartissent une
dernière fois les boîtes
te demander d'aller livrer cette boîte
j'ai mal à la jambe
je ne veux plus de parler tu comprends
rien
je ne peux plus marcher jusque là bas
grosse dispute tous les jours on se
dispute mais on finit toujours par se
réconcilier
ils forment une tribu solidaire et
protège jalousement leur corporation
chaque dawala est propriétaire de sa
clientèle et ne la cède qu'un membre de
sa case
les clients ont confiance en nous on
rentre dans leur maison dans leurs
bureaux seul notre caste a su gagner
leur confiance c'est pourquoi nous
n'autorisons pas d'autres casta devenir
bah voilà
nous seuls avons la force et le courage
de porter chaque jour 60 à 70 kg sur la
tête nous sommes de la caste des mâles
ou et les soldats
nous sommes nés dans les collines et les
montagnes depuis que nous sommes enfants
nous grimpons sur les sommets
la course continue au milieu des
embouteillages il ne reste plus qu'une
heure ou dawala pour livrer les boîtes à
leurs destinataires
à 13 heures précises ce chef
d'entreprise reçoit son repas collecte
et quatre heures plus tôt ce matin par
saatchi et préparé par sa femme
ici ce n'est pas un pays développé
l'eau par exemple n'est pas toujours
potable au moins avec nos repas préparé
par nos femmes toutes les précautions
sont prises
alors que dans les restaurants on n'est
sûr de rien au menu ce midi riz
chou-fleur lentilles des pommes de terre
grâce aux dab à wuala on déjeune à heure
fixe tous les jours
et en plus nous pouvons avoir un moment
tous ensemble
dans le quartier des affaires satchi le
dab à la croix chaque jour ces hommes
qui font l'âme moderne
ça c'est le quartier le plus développé
du pays les gens gagnent beaucoup
d'argent ici à la bourse et c'est grâce
à des endroits comme ça que l'un d'eux
se développe très vite
bombay et le coeur financier du pays la
ville abrite la banque centrale la
bourse et les sièges de nombreuses
sociétés indiennes et étrangères les dab
à aulas ne sont plus autorisés à
s'introduire dans ces temples de la
finance mais pas question pour ses
traders et banquiers de renoncer au
repas maison ils descendent désormais
les gratte ciel pour récupérer leur
boîte codée sur la chaussée
avant ils distribuaient étage par étage
on recevait directement notre déjeuner
au bureau
mais maintenant il faut un badge pour
rentrer à l'intérieur
non on ne peut pas vérifier ce qu'il ya
dans chaque boîte
pourquoi il pourrait y avoir une bombe
ah oui c'est possible
et celui là il n'est pas à moi
non le vôtre gelé mis de côté
tu es sûr que c'est pas le mien les dab
à volants ont su s'adapter aux mesures
de sécurité les clients eux ou encore
quelques difficultés
et celui ci il est pas à vous non c'est
pas le mien non plus
mais vous travaillez vous moi je
travaille au deuxième étage de la bourse
voilà
vous savez ils sont super
ils sont uniques au monde cette façon
qu'ils ont de travail et de livrer des
repas qui viennent de partout et chacun
récupère son repas sans qu'il y ait une
erreur
ma boîte n'a jamais atterri chez
quelqu'un d'autre
et
ben voilà
c'est celle là ma boîte
les tabacs walla ne se trompent qu'une
fois sur 6 millions
la corporation est devenu un cas d'école
ces représentants qui de bombay pour une
université où ils vont présenter leur
ingénieux système
le mois dernier ils étaient reçus par
des avocats bangkok et le prince charles
ne se rend jamais en inde sans venir les
saluer
c'est simple livreur au chapeau blanc
sont devenus des conférenciers très
demandé
je suis vraiment très fier de venir
rencontrer des gens s'ils cultivent et
ça me rend très heureux
ça m'encourage aussi j'ai l'impression
de devenir quelqu'un de très important
mais sur rien côté d'eux
ils sont reçus avec les honneurs par des
étudiants en gestion curieux des secrets
de leur réussite
ponctualité codage des boîtes et esprit
d'équipé
[Musique]
chez nous il y à 0% de nouvelles
technologies et 0% d'investissement
c'est pour ça que nous sommes différents
des autres organisations de services
nous avons seulement de gros bras un
train et de bon vélo voilà notre recette
magique
au bidonville de rajin hagard satchi
termine sa journée de travail il a
parcouru 30 km à vélo 40 km entre un et
quinze kilomètres à pied pour six euros
de salaire
dans la pièce qui sert de maison aussi
membre de sa famille il rejoint son
petit frère le cadet ne rêve pas de
suivre la lignée familiale
mon frère n'a pas pu faire d'études pour
être capable d'entretenir notre famille
si je pouvais avoir un bon travail avec
un meilleur salaire ça changerait tout
ça tu chies continuera lui à porter avec
fierté le fameux chapeau blanc
je suis très fier d'être un tabac où
elle a malgré la difficulté chaque moto
notre système est si efficace que nous
sommes reconnus partout dans le monde on
nous observe parce que nous sommes
différents et c'est vrai nous avons
quelque chose de particulier